oh it is time for drew's news and with
me at the desk every person's dream
pilot ross max yes hi everybody
we know weddings cost a pretty penny oh
my god and we found one interesting way
to attack that bill now
i i found this story quite controversial
okay so newsweek reports that a person
on reddit says their friend katie is a
bride to be and she recently told her
friends that she'd be sending around her
venmo account so that they could quote
unquote chip in for the wedding costs
ross
yes
thoughts you're about to get married i
am and katie girl i feel your pain this
venmo i i'm about to pass around the
bucket here in the audience collection
seriously i mean i i we're not i i
thought to myself when i first found out
how much the flowers were for a wedding
can i hold a bake sale to raise funds i
see flowers on the side of the road you
want to charge me what it is shocking
how much these things are so katie get
your friends to all chip in
genius katie genius
refinery29 reports that a new makeup
hack can make them disappear all you
have to do is take your concealer
ideally a tone or two down from your
foundation
and draw a fun pair of glasses on your
face and then of course make sure you
blend don't leave it like that basically
what i think this is great for is do you
know how in the bronzing world we have
the magic three
um this is what how you're supposed to
bronze it's called the magic three it's
a backwards three on your face
rossi you're doing it of course i'm
doing it hello perfect
so if we have information about where
we're supposed to bronze maybe we need
the glasses hack for where we're
supposed to conceal everybody needs a
facial road map bronze
conceal
okay
well um do i look better
so hard
do you have a beauty blender dude i do
have a blender okay so now i'm going to
blend yeah okay here you go i think i'm
starting to look pretty great oh god
okay
if you're about to walk down that aisle
but you're agonizing over crafting that
perfect wedding speech we've got a
solution
metro reports that you can now hire a
ghostwriter for your wedding you've
already got a florist and a caterer so
why not a wordsmith the company is
called speechy and they write
personalized speeches for brides grooms
best men's wacky aunts you name it and
they really do a deep dive to make these
personal they interview you beforehand
and craft something unique specific and
cliche free for anyone who thinks this
is unromantic the company says the
grooms get in touch months in advance
because they just want to get it right
well let me ask you out of the gate
um because you're about to get married
how would you feel if you i know
i know
how would you feel if wellington
resourced with speeches
okay let's talk about it
so i have mixed emotions about this
topic one i'm like no and then i'm like
wait a second you know you think about
it as a skill set you know i'm good at
certain things you know but algebra i'm
not good at roofing i'm not good at so i
would hire someone to roof my house for
me so if you don't have the particular
skill set of writing your intentions and
your thoughts down maybe this would work
for you that being said wellington my
fiance
don't you dare get your instagram feed
fired up because we've got an account
that you must follow unilad reports that
this photographer captures incredible
freeze frames of dogs catching treats
okay the photographer is christian
vealer and he's been taking these action
shots for years and i gotta tell you
this is exactly what i look like when my
postmates are wrong
that's what i would look like at the
barbecue place eating the ribs totally
absolutely with the ex-boyfriend who's
got a bloated sense of self and thinks
it's all about him this is so cute you
know like
imagine how many outtakes he has because
you ever tried to take a picture of your
dog for like a christmas card or
something and getting the it's just
impossible yeah it's me with the kids
i'm taking pictures of us all the time
and it's like maybe one a year do i get
that's like semi-passable yeah here's a
tip if you take a picture of your dog
get a squeaky toy and squeak it in like
oh that's cute well maybe you should
follow christian zeeler and throw treats
and like i mean those pictures are just
joy yeah and